[音楽]
car
みなさんこんにちは
じゃーん
ご紹介いただきましたね腰の伊藤と申しますん
私は2006年に日向台んがという人権だったいっ
もう立ち上げて東京を置いて10年間
ページェント暴飲沸騰しています
皆さんで gan
あゆ姉気があると思いますけど
私はそうですね
人が自分らしく
そういうことでいいんじゃないですか
ge 2
ところが私が活動している間にも非常に日本でも世界
19でひなせています
だから私たち活動を続けて
技術ん
えわたしたちの活動家近くの
はシンク台巡見使がもぐらいにあった
ているそうね
あってこれはねそして解決を高めるというところにする
なぜと同じ動画集ないん
gac ライフは力の強いとゲームを持ってる人から
力の弱い人
そして税金ができなさそうな人に対して向けられている
そして被害にあうと
被害者の方は一層グループは確かに分かれ
声掛けられない状況になってしまう
そうすると多くの場合人権侵害という事態は収束などに上がった頃
闇公募やそして津美
私たちはその3位海嶺
できればその闇往復していきたいということで発動して
皆さんはこの a 2
したくみーというという
私の10月
アメリカのセレブ十分たちが次々と
はい覆う輸入車
受けた政府の豪力そしてセクシャルハラスメントる被害を
という動きにいました
1990年代から綿々と続いた政治が
が仲人紛失のもとにされたっ
そして
10月15日今年の18中央2死
このカフェの被害にあった人
乳酸ある者みお
twitter へ
全米の星たちにいる理由
ラッキーだろそんなに深刻なんだから
ここと思う
日立以外にありましたね
みーつーというハッシュタグを付け
シェアしていきません
その翌日までに何と全米で10万回
以上です
シートがを移行して私も被害に遭いました
ん
ことをこういう風に
そしてさらにこれが世界中になって
外貨でのヨーロッパリーグ2
で私もいない
鳥越がああ
れていた
ヨーロッパでは政治家の方々まで3私もいばいい
ん
4男性政治たからも被害に g で2やつ
そして今前次回
性豪運じゃないと
声が非常に強く願ってい
では日本はどうでしょう
一部で少し盛り上がりを見せていますけれども
少しどうでしょまだ盛り上がりがチビ bews
私は日本では声を上げたい人結婚で環境があるのではないか
いうふうにへ
ん
例えば地域通った
その人が美人でたいと歓談する
マナーかえでぃーすわけないですん
h あるじゃないかというようなもんだよとか
そして美人だと判断された
入りとなるじゃないかそんな汚い言葉を使っています
そして意外な地質弾としていっ
まあ被害者ん
そういった光弾きました
たとえます
男性吸収の良いです
そんな格好をしていたみたのだろう
どんな話あら探しばかりしてい
大小種類
そして肝心の課題焼成
状況だった
見受けられます
そういう状況子供のころから見ていた若い女性たちが
勇気を出して声をあげるということが難しいということは当然だと私は思います
深刻なのはその結果男性たち
勘違いをしてしまっている
ということではないかと思います
よし7月 nhk のあさイチというずばうん
男性に対する会う程度がいい
ここで性行為の同意があったと思われても仕方がない
パターンのかということを撮りました
人気だった
無事排気が入っています
秘境4でした
うん
すいませんでした大丈夫かはいよかったですハイ
ではここから進めていきますねはい
ではこの朝市のアンケートを見ていきます
2人で淫臭をした場合27%の男性が
そして女性が露出度の高い格好をしていた場合13%の男性だ
そして女性は泥酔していた場合にはなんと35%の男性が性行為の同意があったと考え
られても仕方がないというふうに回答したんですねっ
皆さん女性からのいうところへどう思います
非常にとんでもないですよねこんなことでは売っ日に男性と一緒に飲みに行ったりも
出来ません
そして麗水して言うなら解放してほしい
良いでも末てって欲しいと思うのに性行為をするなんてとんでもない話だと思いません
か
ところがこのアンケートでもわかる通り本当にこのような非常識がまるで常識のように
まかり通っているわけだ
そして残念ながら
これは世間だけではなく司法の世界でも同様なんです
この女性伊藤史織さんという方は
男性のじゃあな人と一緒に会食をした後突然
意識がなくなったそして気がついた時にはいい反する性的暴行を受けていた
ということでこの被害について男性をレイプの犯罪で刑事告訴をしました
ところが検察が口を出した結論これは何だったかというと
不起訴という結論だったんですね
彼女だけではないです
私は弁護士ですのでこういったケースをたくさん見てきましたけれども
性犯罪そうですね女性から見てどう見ても同意があったと思えないような性被害の事案
でも加害者の方が処罰をされるということは本当に稀ですその都度
被害者が増やし涙にくれるこれを私もたくさん見てきました
しかし私は思うのですこういった告発も今出ています
だからこそ
性暴力に寛容な社会を今すぐ変えていかなければならない
私はそのことを強く皆さんに行きたいと思います
性行為には明確な同意が必要です
相手から明確な同意がない場合性行為をすることは許されません
このことをきちっとしたルートしていくことが必要ではないでしょうか
日本の刑法は意に反するすべての性行為を処罰するように法改正されるべきです
私はこのことを強く歌いたいと思っています
そして社会の意識もぜひ変わって欲しいと思います
特に若い人たちに訴えたい
性行為で傷つく人が出ないように話も人が出ないように
みんなで話し合って新しい性に関する会社を作っていってほしいなというふうに強く
望みます
そしてセクシャルハラスメントについても同様です
これについてはすでに明確なルールがいろんなところで決まっていますね
それでも世界は横行していますこれは
じんじんいうところが作っている規則です
みてください明確なルールがあります
これがきちんと実施されていればセクハラに苦しむ人も減っていくでしょう
ぜひ皆さんでこういうことを知ってそして議論していってほしいなというふうに思って
います
こちらの先ほどの伊藤4ヨーイさん
自分と同じ被害い合う人がいなくなるようにと思ってあえて実名で被害を告発し訴えて
います
その彼女の勇気に対して応援してくれる人ももちろんいます
ところが心ないバッシングも結構あると言うんですよね
皆さんどうでしょうそして最近きました最近日本でも迷宮のハッシュタグをつけて
インターネットでつぶやく人に対して心ない
バッシングがいるというのです
これではなかなか運動が出て進んでいかないですよね
声を上げた人に対して主が進んでいくということがあると声を上げられない無数の人
たちも含めて将来にわたって泣き寝入りをしなければならない
そんな社会がそんな観光が続いていきます
ですから私たちが今すべきことは
声を上げた人を一人にしないこと
そして勇気を出して声を上げた人の声を受け止めてできることなら応援していくことで
はないでしょうか
私たちヒューマンライツナーガ取り組んだ活動の一つに
アダンとビデオの出演共有もん day というものがあります
これは若い女性がモデルにならないか
タレントならないということをかいうされそして騙されて契約書にサインした途端
入った仕事はアダルトビデオそして契約書にサインした以上
義務がありますそしてこれをやらないとすれば多額の違約金を払わなければならない
そんな小分けで
沢山の女性達が av
の出演を強要されてくる cd という深刻な人権侵害でした
私たちもこれを知った時は本当に驚きました
しかし被害者の方々のお話を聞きながら
調査報告しを昨年ぬ録画昨年するさんですね3月にまとめて発表しました
これは大きく報道されましたけれどもその時にわたしたちを待っていたのはそして被害
者の方々を持っていたのはそんなのはでっち上げではないかという大きなバッシングの
声でした
しかしそんなバッシングの最中に
被害者の方々が
実は私も被害にあいましたということを
実名で声を上げて告発をしてくれました
そうした告発があるたびにメディアが大きく取り上げ
そしてこれが社会問題となり
そして今年の5月日本政府はこの av 出演教養問題は女性に対する重大な人権侵害
であるということで政府としてきちんとした対策をとっていくということを決定し現在
実行に移しています
あのバッシングが
非常に日厳しかったとき
女性たちが声を上げてくれなかったら今頃どうなっていただろうというふうに私は思う
んですね
そして勇気を出して声を上げてくれた女性たちに対して
多くの心ある男性たち
女性たちが
ずっと応援をして励ましてくれましたそれが本当に心強かったというふうに私は思って
います
皆さん
最近声を上げる人たちに対してはなかなか厳しいして羽化向けられることが多いですね
例えば性暴力の被害だけでなくても今年であっても黒会社がに会え air という
ところに対してそこの待遇が悪いということを訴えた障害者の男性
そして熊本市議会で議場に子供を連れて入ろうとした女性の方がいい
その方々がまるでトラブルメーカーであるかのようにバッシングの対象になるかという
ことがありました
そのば寝具のないようなんだったかというと声を上げた人
権力をまあ主張した人たちがどちらかというと調整が不足している
既存のルールを守らなかった
そういうことでマガシの対象になったのです
しかし皆さん考えてくださいよくこの人たちの訴えを聞いてみるとじつは障害者にとっ
てアクセスしやすい社会を求めている
そして子育て世代が政治や社会にもっと参加できるようにしたいという風に考えている
そういった本当の伝えたかった議論に私たちが誠実に向き合って話し合っていけば実は
もっと良い社会を作れたのではないかというふうに思うと私はとても残念に思ってい
ます
少し遡ってみましょう1960年代アメリカ
公民権運動というものが起きて北人に対する人種差別はよくないという動画公表しまし
た
ほどきっかけとなったものは何かというと一人の若い女性だ
当時白人しか座れないバスの責任
あえて座ってそして既存の秩序に no ということを
声をあげてまあ行動で示した
その結果彼女は逮捕されてしまったんですねだけれども彼女の声に
励まされ行動に励まされ共感を持った人たちが
燎原の火の如く
黒人差別を許さないという運動を作りそして公民警報ができた
こうしてアメリカの歴史は大きく変わりました
日本なも同じ1960年たり起きたことがあります
それは皆さん知らないかもしれないですけれども当時女性は30歳で職場を丁寧にし
なければならないという不当なそういったルールが全国つく to love だーの
会社でありました
女性たちは仕方がないので我慢して30歳に丁寧していました
ところがある1人の女性がこれはおかしいということで会社を訴えたらです
裁判に訴えてそしてこのルールは憲法違反です
というふうに言いました
確かに憲法は
男女平等を規定しています会社のルールであっても憲法に反する差別を含むものは無効
になります
最高裁判所はそのように射止めて彼女を勝たせました
こうして女性だけ30歳で丁寧しなければならないというルールが全国で撤廃されたん
です
女性も
ずっと働き続けていきたい当たり前の要求ですよね
でもそんな当たり前の事でもこの1人の女性がおかしいということを声をあげなければ
未だにもしかしたら続いていたかもしれないのです
私たちはこういう声を上げる人の恩恵を打っていま
どちら様生きているんですね
私たちは
不当なルールを課しな慣習があった場合
声を上げてそれを変えていくことができる
そしてその出発点となるのがまず一番最初に声を上げる人
んですね
声を上げる人というのは
トラブルメーカーではなく
チェンジメーカーなんだというふうに私は思います
だからこそ声を上げている人をバッシングするのではなくその人たちの声にきちんと耳
を傾け
音質で応援していくことが必要ではないでしょうか
私は人権侵害人権問題取り組んでいますので前傾信頼がなどがピコースっていうのは
いつも同じだというふうに思っています
一つは加害性が圧倒的に強いこと
そして被害者が弱い立場に置かれていて孤立させられていること
3つ目だ社会の昔もしくは被害者への避難や冷たい態度だと思います
私たちの力でこの1番と2番強い問題
これを変えることは難しいかもしれません
たとえ度もこの3番目ここにはアプローチをして私たちの考え次第で変えていくことが
できるのではないでしょうか
声を上げる人いいの
向かうし人権問題への無冠詞
それを関心に変えてそして被害者への避難冷たい視線から応援に変わっていけば
長く続く人権侵害の問題も解決し社会全体が良い方向に行きやすい方向に変えていける
のではないかというふうに私は信じています
差別や人権侵害未だにたくさん続いています
しかし声を上げる人に寄り添って応援し
そして共感し一緒に行動することを通じて私たちは私たちにとってもっとより良い社会
をつくっていくことができるのではないかと信じて活動しています
私もそんな想いをもとにこれからも活動していきたいなというふうに思っています
ハッシュタグみー2声をあげられる社会をみんなで作っていきましょう
どうもありがとうございました
[拍手]